[Music]
invent session news submitted by sadboys
a private Facebook group with TSA
workers was discovered to have tons of
crude and violent remarks hey why they
leaking this locker room Tom yeah no
that's what I was saying like whatever
we're talking about it you know one of
my favorite things was when Fox 11 did
an undercover spot on gangs working at
the airport and then they were like next
on Fox 11 did you know that your
airplane baggage might be being packed
away by a gang member
did you ever watch the segment that was
just like that actually no I waited to
like watch it cuz it was like so all
they're doing is doing their job but
they just so happened to be thanked
member yeah well they're tagging all
over I know they're literally tagged
like so you know this cart that they
push and then there's like hallways and
bathrooms and there's dang graffiti in
the [ __ ] tunnel what are they tagging
my luggage right you know let's stop
representing everywhere yeah but it's
funny you gotta let them know where you
from mark kitty music oh [ __ ] I guess I
was representative so I think you know
I'm sorry it's a part of what he has to
do it I like it this private Facebook
page that is not directly associated
with TSA corsola which is US
Transportation Security Administration
it's not citizen to Joe Mallya it's a
private Facebook group that people can
join I didn't know that oh I did yes I
did it's fair enough oh wow you did that
without even knowing if you drive it
hand pick only cool people could join so
it is the same how do we apply yes join
and then I'll watch your face and go I
like you okay come on you just judging
by the face do you deny people all the
time trolls fake accounts there are a
lot of people from Africa that join
multiple groups and they try to sell
stuff like stammers yeah at first I just
let I was like oh I have fans from all
these life African country I didn't know
that that's awesome and I would bring
them in and then they start trying to
sell [ __ ] all day long they're not a fan
and I was like oh this is a tactic that
they use they just join a ton
yeah I see I don't know just things like
beanbag chairs and [ __ ] I think it's
like Nigerian prince cams like so when I
see and read it I'm like ah I got to
delete this yeah but I bet you let
highlight he's in yeah but sometimes
they're fake too
I see careful if they're too hot it's
fake yeah because I don't think my fan
is ever that too hot oh just insulted
all your fans no no you know what
I take that back there are some really
hot fans that I'm surprised at their
fans yep Slater wooden so this private
Facebook page has more than 18,000
currents and or former employees of the
TSA precise and southern kissing like
for example one post here has an exposed
[ __ ] idiots of the world
[ __ ] idiots of the world making my
job harder I hope your plane blows up
after the week we've had at BWI I think
we need a third boarding pass code in
addition to llll and SS SS some of our
passengers need to be designated D AM F
translation dumbass [ __ ] what
you've never found on your thing and
then you need like a secondary thing you
know what though the TSA has gotten a
lot [ __ ] better I have to say like
their customer service or just the way
they treat passengers since [ __ ] fact
it goes oh my god that's not it used to
be so glad you'd have like some stupid
[ __ ] that's like frustrated and
just they're mad because the passing
like they can't explain things to the
passenger and they're frustrated and I'm
like who the [ __ ] train here I agree but
the shoes has to go the shoes thing has
to go has to go you guys aren't
pre-check yeah get pre-check you don't
have to take off your shoes oh really
yeah boy and you don't have to take your
laptop out and if you
Jackie you give the jacket on and can we
stop doing this [ __ ] machine already
because I know it doesn't work they've
done several [ __ ] studies about it it
doesn't work the pre check you go to the
metal detector one yeah exactly metal
detector do ID you just asked but you
got loaded really family party
you can opt out if you don't want that
machine you go can somebody touch my
balls yeah you go for the patent it
that's the secret code somebody touched
my balls I just want the metal detector
one all right next one I like the
pat-down cuz it feels good no it's my
baggage day and a lovely passenger
decides to leave a nice note for me in
her bag she says we can't touch anything
and if we do to call her clearly I don't
want any smoke with the HEPA so I call
my lead over and so eloquently state and
so eloquently states after that note
touch everything clearly I'm not the
insubordinate type so what do I do
I touch everything in said bag to add an
extra sprinkle of petit because clearly
the cow took me there I took a half
stack of inspection notices and threw it
in a bag and went on about my petty day
oh damn one of the story
don't try to out petty TSA we win every
time hmm Wow why would they not want
them to touch anything yeah I mean o-m-g
I need to buy a lotto ticket
we just screened a whole group of
Chinese tourists without having to call
a single bag check impossible
that's impossible Eva no rice cookers no
hundreds of bottles of vitamins no
frozen food house way how that's in my
mom's luggage your mom would pack a rice
cooker no but like vitamins she's like a
vitamin smuggler I shall always bring
[ __ ] from here to Taiwan cuz like some
of this stuff's just really expensive
over there and then she'll buy like
whatever vitamins that she can't get in
the States from over there and bring it
over if she goes back and forth all the
time I was watching this show it's kind
of like Australian TSA and they they
basically have to check the luggage and
all that and I was like how interesting
is this gonna be but it's pretty [ __ ]
dope so there was this one family coming
from Thailand and I was like damn why
they got to be Asian but then it's
pretty predictable they literally had
boxes of [ __ ] that they just wrapped up
with saran wrap right and when you open
it up
fish that they newspapers up and they're
like oh my god and it's kind of going
bad you know cuz it was a refrigerated
and [ __ ] though it was ice that was on
it but it was melting and it was just
soaked up and they were unraveling it
and it was [ __ ] catfish and mud it
was just like and what did they say
they're like fish is so expensive that's
what I'm wondering is like is there
special fish that you just cannot get I
mean the catfish Italian is pretty good
yeah that's pretty good
well I mean in the flight is is it is it
quicker cuz it's Australia I don't know
but it's just crazy to eat it there you
can't take it at all man I know that's
what blows my mind is they don't have
like airport ready vacuum sealed produce
like they do that all the time but I
don't know I thought was but don't know
you're not supposed to smuggle produce
and [ __ ] anything yeah I think one time
my family definitely got stopped because
my mom was it was all the [ __ ] was like
um it was dehydrated [ __ ] though and I
think like dehy did like shrimp like
that [ __ ] you would put in like soup and
maybe some Sun like some fish but it was
all dehydrate it wasn't like a whole ass
fresh fish yeah did they throw it away
I don't remember we also got stopped
because my mom brought wax fruit so the
battle was real fruit oh yes you bought
these little um it was like like little
wax lights you that she wanted to put in
the house yeah it looks like display
yeah I remember they caught geo would
orange and treat her like a drug
smuggler it was ridiculous well you
bought orange but it was orange that
that you saved from the plane all right
it wasn't even orange from here yeah
yeah and then you got the dog zombies
like whoa he's just an orange like an
orange sniffing maybe have a good mimic
it was funny cuz I was like that's
pretty that was pretty [ __ ] extreme
for a [ __ ] orange he do that and then
they found it they're like oh get rid of
it I felt so guilty I was like bug my
bed I know how they're gonna get rid of
it now then sir if I see
but the seed they're all about the see
the chuckit we burn it it was in thunder
what a face like an orange tree starts
sprouting out of no there's an
incinerator doesn't happen often and
I'll tell you those ghosts are growing
on it doesn't this one I don't think I
hate hate hate hate hearing well I went
through another airport and he didn't
say anything [ __ ] I don't care this is
my airport and my checkpoint and this is
how we do it here
hashtag preach reply when a cop pulls
you over for speeding do you tell him
that you go that you go that speed every
day and no one's ever stopped me before
make it right just cuz you got away with
it before other reply they didn't say
anything at the last airport me cut off
lisam TSA is one of the only jobs where
you have to do customer service with
thousands of people yeah a day imagine
getting moded that'd be time I can see
why the TSA people are so irritated all
the time yeah understand that there's
some people that fly for the very first
time and they just don't [ __ ] know
yeah and then and then people at [ __ ]
stadiums and she'd got to deal with so
many people yeah dude I was just at
Party City of the day getting prompts
from me and if you're doing a sketch
right
and there's this thing by the door or
this [ __ ] monster robot guy goes and
there's a little kid in the cage that's
screaming its [ __ ] head off and it
does it every time somebody walks in the
store so it's doing it like every 30
seconds and the person by the register
who's right by the thing is just like
[ __ ] it hate everything you could just
see it okay can't I can't emphasize
enough that these guys even when I do
see those people that have never flown
before I mean even when I'm just behind
them I be getting irritated you know
what come on bear you have a [ __ ]
take your [ __ ] belt off dawg take
your you doing I tell them forty
stripping along the way they said
laptops out 70 [ __ ] five times
seventy five time in here wait take a
laptop out till you get up to the belt
let these people talk some [ __ ] then
they're like wait
what is it what is it then when they
walk all the way up it's like how are
you not the [ __ ] no they say it's so
sticking up pretty you say people say a
statement we have TSA fans a lot oh dude
so much so much TSA love so TSA said the
TSA breakroom Facebook page is not
affiliated with TSA it is a private site
that is neither affiliated nor endorsed
by TSA as such TSA does not water to
recite the code of conduct for TSA
employees provides that an employee's
off-duty internet use must not adversely
reflect on TSA or negatively impact its
mission cause embarrassment to the
agency or cause the public and or TSA to
question the employees reliability
judgment and trustworthiness our
workforce is strongly encouraged to
report illegal and unethical behavior
wherever and whenever they see it
employees can report suspected
misconduct to TSA office of
Investigations via phone or online
tsa voles is employees to the highest
professional and ethical standards and
has zero tolerance for illegal and
immoral conduct that's all things
because of the one comment about like
the plane blowing up a little much try
holding your breath while tip is reading
that don't tell you while you're doing
the comments
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]